per tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono familiari soldati su
long as e voglio farvi vedere una morte
pazzesca perché durante l'episodio è
successo che sono morto tra un po corto
questo video come far vedere che quando
ne sono molto tempo storie sono morto
con colli sbagliatissima ma ci hanno
avuto un culo così che non c'entravo
niente però deve farlo quella dell'iva
[Musica]
va bene ragazzi partita giocata con i
campi si dice è la cosa più fringe che
abbia mai visto che noi avevano
ammazzare che l'aia mi vuole ammazzare
che noi avevamo alzare che noi avevamo
hazare che dovevo ammazzare non mi ha
ammazzato grazie che noia la mia task
preferita finalmente arrivata come
perfect match su fonda è strano
prenderla e buttarla nel cielo sarà
niente io l'ala era piuttosto moriamo ma
non faccio la parte dell'agenzia
definire questo ok perfetto nuovo chi è
morto
ma che servono per spese sia che
rapiscono posso parlare magari è stato
bruttissimo perché ho detto no non
voglio stare qui che fanno la kill di
gruppo e hanno fatto la kelly brook io
non voglio accusare nessuno quella che
mi sembrava più vicino al cadavere che
era lì era che noia ma detto qui non ho
mai i suoi quasi sicuro del visto
accordi che proprio chi è più vicino e
non è perché si fanno scarti no io ho
visto lo scalo
sono a pisa che che noia raga non
l'abbiamo data perché c'era stato troppo
tempo io non voglio votare io non ha
posto la gente
imparate la non gas a non fidarmi della
scelta noi quando uno dice lui a cocaine
no
mannaggia quindi dovete stare attenti e
pensare solo con la vostra testa poi
prendete gli altri come se ti va adesso
pietro mi sta seguendo se mi ammazza io
lo picchio cioè non è che ci si può far
niente chiusa la porta qua e uno di noi
uno è sicuramente etro larga non so
perché ce l'ho con pietro oggi non ce
l'abbiamo avuta con pietro è il sale
fondamento però si muove in modo troppo
scaltro oddio che è morto corpi
navigation ma non ho visto né faglia
mentre eravamo totalmente via allora
telecamere hanno visto la ragazzina è
stata fatta quando s'è fatto d'accordo
anche il rettore probabilmente qui mi
sono troppo signore fa quindi io sono
state molto vessicchio che era l'unico
che aveva che aveva linea elettrica
cesko divina elettrica non ho idea di
chi sia pietro e allora adesso vediamo
se entrato il solo adesso di vado gli
faccia a faccia con essa le palle ci hai
le palle e ce l'hai
dai non puoi uccidere tutti e due perché
poi solo uno ai ragazzi di fido di cesca
ti prego grazie all'orario grazie siete
degli stolti
tanto io mi ricordo di vessicchio
vabbè ci ha capito la nostra è una
sorpresa manca secondo me pietro l'aria
è vero ma ok allora sono io tanto mi
votate al prossimo turno
allora
uno che vince sanzione colpa della mia
persona la mia depressiva l'avevo capito
subito martina marito comunque martin ha
perso tutto
[Musica]
allora fino invece l'ha imposto allora
vediamo di riuscire a far la partita
decente
vado a fare un po di tusk gli autori
camente ammazzare qualcuno non sarebbe
male non sarebbe male fa ammazzare
qualcuno all'inizio
ok è comandato qua amarci e dentro devo
ammazzare qualcuno all'inizio con il
problema ragazzi se non ammazzava una
lite che all'inizio il problema è
proprio questo
pian piano diventa molto più semplice
però all'inizio è sempre occasione bari
fare la giocata oggi l'impostore allora
arci dove la cavate giocare asta ragazze
ragazzi la mette nel mirino su di lei
aspetta la l'ho chiamato io parlo io
allora io sto vicino ahmed ben ami ha
visto mi ha passato il report sotto e
niente sono stato lì ho visto fiere
morto basta allora io ero davanti ammar
ci marci sta venendo in caffetteria gli
arrivò vicino luigi no no no no no sei
tu sei tu allora se sei tu te lo giuro
scusa ma se arrivano allora non solo da
te se io ti ho visto tu sei tornato
indietro no no perché ho visto il
bottone reports sotto ha senso ha senso
la telecamera che può dire però ero io
ma possiamo mettere che si scopre chi è
in fondo non ho capito perché lui vale
che sia
allora vi sia piaciuto ragazzi che sta
un po amareggiata virare la mamma mia
che cacchio per una volta è vero ha
votato fa una partita decente non
abbiamo fatto ancora nulla prof
ciao in tutti i miei piani malefici ma
ha rovinati così con una cosa hanno
vinto non meritando che poi non l'ho più
non aveva più fatto vedere come finisce
la partita ma alla fine hanno vinto ma
non sa sono merita non se la sono non se
la scrivetevi scegliamo da ragazzi
[Musica]